while you're staying home you need to
post a video or a sign like this one
saying who you're gonna stay home for
and you tagged six friends so they do
the same and since we're all connected
by various degrees trust me I know we
can work together to stay home and keep
each other safe and spread the word
I'm here with Kevin Bacon Kevin thank
you so much for joining us my first
question is did you ever think that six
degrees of Kevin Bacon would play into a
cause like this with this challenge
you've started I don't think that
anybody nobody it could you know imagine
where we're at at this moment right here
but the one thing I'll say is that I've
always believed that six degrees was not
ultimately about me you know I think
that the you know the game was sort of
fun and and you know it took off you
know because there was a you know kind
of acting and celebrity component to it
but the truth is that you know people
are really hungry for connections and
that that's the that's why social media
you know took off so specifically and
that's why you know good Facebook was so
huge when it first came out it because
all of us are are looking for ways to be
connected and sadly for better for worse
I think this virus is really kind of
pointed that up in a really really
extreme way it's really hitting home so
on the on the on the down side of things
you know we can see the connections
between people in the way that it's
spread in the way that people get
affected on on the up side of things I
think we realized that the things that
we do in our in our neighborhoods and
the things we do on this side of the
world that are going to affect people
and in other places as well and we're
all just kind of riding this big boat
together it certainly puts things in
perspective and so you have started this
I stay home for challenge and you're
playing off of that six degrees of
separation a bit as well so tell us
about how you came up with the idea for
it and maybe just explain the basics of
it well we were just kind of thinking of
a way to you know
I don't know just do something we've got
a lot of time and sitting at home and
started thinking about the idea that you
stay home for someone that you care
about because if you go out and you
interact with someone you know you may
not get that person sick or that person
may not get you sick but they may get
somebody else that we don't kind of you
know be connected through across a
series of six degrees and then you you
you
we all have somebody in our lives that
is important to us and that's a good
reason to stay home every one of us has
someone who is worth staying home for
and I am staying home for kyra sedgwick
yeah ah speak of the devil what I'm
doing something you are just encouraging
people to stay home and stay home as
much as possible to halt the spread of
coronavirus and you want everybody to
tag and post a video or a picture of who
they're staying home for you said of
course the wonderful Kyra Sedgwick you
guys are one of those golden couples in
Hollywood that we all love so much
you've been together a long time I got
to ask you how are you doing staying at
home together so much and what tips do
you have for the other couples out there
changing their daily routines yeah it's
yeah it's funny I mean we you know
absence makes the heart grow fonder
they'd say right well you know I mean I
also think that there's a there's an
opportunity here to get into it even
deeper level of a relationship but we we
try we keep our communication lines open
as much as possible we started
meditating together which is something
we've never done before here all of a
sudden said I want to do a puzzle I
don't think we've ever done a puzzle in
32 years in 31 years knowing each other
and we have this you know puzzle that's
sitting right on our coffee table I
don't know if we'll ever do it but but
she wanted to have a puzzle so you know
new stuff you know we're experimenting
with I don't know different ways to cook
things out of the pantry we made this
terrible what we had the other day you
know and play music you know
we have a lot of instruments around the
house and you know we'll just start I
don't know
playing something I absolutely love that
again things are put in perspective
you've been together for 30 years and
you're doing some things for the very
first time now that you're at home and
you guys are probably used to I mean
you're both such incredibly talented
working actors so you're spending long
days on set or you're traveling and I
would imagine it maybe has been a while
since you've spent this much time at
home together yeah yeah
we're both very very busy and you know
bouncing all over the place so so yeah
this is this is the most time we spent
together in a long time you love the
ones you're with it's the definition and
what about your kids and the rest of
your family how is everybody and how is
everybody kind of staying strong through
this really well thank you thank you for
asking
we're I think that all of us are if
there's this there's two pieces of it
one is that we have to kind of close the
circle right to close the circle of
friends that we're actually connecting
with and the people that we're seeing
and I think as the news is come out with
all of them is kind of starting to limit
limit limit limit be able to come in
contact with on the other hand I think
there's a lot of time and we should all
remember to take advantage of this time
to reach out for the people that we love
we do have these kinds of you know
whatever chatting you really want to see
somebody not just picking up the phone
and calling and you know it's it's it's
good just to connect with family and
friends I'm and I just a lot of old
friends are reaching out to me you know
I just got a email from an old old buddy
of mine just saying hey I'm talking and
you know a couple months and you know
it's it's it's it's it's cool well I
wanted to ask you I mean I think one
news item hit not just Hollywood but
everyone because he's such a beyond
beloved person but when Tom Hanks and
Rita Wilson got it I mean we were all
taken aback and of course he was your
co-star in one of the best movies of all
time Apollo 13 is he's somebody who
you've talked to I know he's been giving
people updates but have you had you
spoken at Tom and Rita through all this
we have we've exchanged emails and I'm
you know they're very much of my
thoughts crazy about the guy he's not
only a you know incredible actor but
just a real real great man and and Rita
as well and yeah yeah I mean I think
that it's interesting how somebody that
is that beloved was so early you know in
the I mean now work now we're at a place
where I think we're gonna see a lot of
people in her that are well-known but
the way that the way that he came right
out which by the way I'll do and and
said this is a real thing and he also
said and were you know gonna be okay I
think it was very very powerful and
beautiful you know kind of move on his
part
thinking about it every day yeah well I
want to talk about who you so other
celebrities an hour are of course
jumping all over this amazing challenge
of yours I stay home for and who you
tagged because you tagged six people
Jimmy Fallon Demi Lovato Elton John
Kevin Hart Brandi Carlile and David
Beckham
so everybody's fascinated to know you
know why would Kevin Bacon pick people
six degrees why did you choose those
people oh it was just kind of you know
he's kind of it was sort of a I have to
say it was sort of a group conversation
that we that we we had because you know
there's this weird idea that since it's
me you know I had everybody on my speed
dial and you know I mean that's not
really the way my my life is you know
everybody wants to be bacon all of my
friends are nuts
you know superstars but I just thought
about each of these people for different
reasons
were people that you know III admire
either their you know whatever music or
humor or athleticism or talent or you
know whatever it happens to be and also
they're in some cases their activism and
and I don't know it was was it pretty
it's a pretty random list it was kind of
a it was sort of a brain it was sort of
a brainstorm I just thought I don't know
you know I mean I you know I adore the
guy adore you know his music Anna adore
everything that that that he's done in
terms of you know he was so active early
on during the age crisis and you know
just is such a great dude and you know
so I just popped into my head and he was
one of the first people to respond so
well I did do I get it puts in
perspective look even if you don't know
somebody personally we're all connected
through this and we can all affect
others through this
did anybody DM you back I don't know if
even with all these six people if you've
met them all before but if not like dude
Demi Lovato say hey thanks for tagging
me or anything
well Demi Lovato popped into my head
because very early on years ago I was I
was on a television show called the
following and she reached out and said
you know I just really really loved that
show and I'd love to come visit the set
and I really wanted it to happen because
I was like you know real fan of hers and
and then you know it never it just kind
of didn't didn't happen so way way back
in the back of my mind I thought well
maybe a parent a parent she has a few
followers I don't know you know she's
got good she's got about 50 million
followers more than idea well well you
know you can you picked a great list to
of a diverse list people who can reach
out to all different types of
communities with their following which I
think again is what we need right now to
spread that awareness well I also want
to say that one of the cool things about
this thing is that because there's this
hashtag
you know I stay at home for you know I
can look at all the
all the responses and it's it's really
great of course you don't throw the the
celebs and jumped on board and I hope
anymore do we keep spreading it in that
way because they have the power to
spread it that way but also just you
know individual people and and and like
I said that people who are you know in
the out on the front lines have also
responded in in their own in their own
way saying you know I'm out here so that
you could stay home and and and I think
that's really powerful and I also think
there's there's things that you know we
can we can do I mean it's a six degrees
daughter work you know I'm sure we have
places there that we can point you
towards in terms of like you know things
that you can do to help besides of you
know posting a video you know this is
going to be a lot of people that are
hungry there's a lot of food banks in in
your areas that need help and there's no
Kid Hungry the American Red Cross
there's a lot of ways we can help so
awesome thank you so much um before I
let you go I do want to ask you one more
question about one person you just have
one degree from UM when all this is or
hopefully Apollo 13 turns 25 in June
that is a movie to be celebrated when
you look back did you have any idea when
you were making that movie that you know
years and years from it coming out it
would be such an impactful film still I
think it you know we felt like we were
making something special and I think
that we we were really super tapped into
NASA into that story and into the the
history of the space program and we
could feel you know actual astronauts
getting excited about the movie that we
were making
I mean Hanks I think he I think he
learned so much about the space program
I think he could fly the shuttle
honestly I he would just rattle this
stuff off it just blew my mind and and
Bill Paxton the late great Bill Paxton
was also really super super he
into it and and it did it did feel like
you know Ron was making something from
that was really gonna laugh I was just
digging around my basement with recently
and this behind-the-scenes footage of us
on the zero-g airplane also known as the
Vomit Comet and I had it I had all the
footage
digitized because I I didn't know if
anybody else had seen it and it's really
it's really wild because you know a lot
of people it's a long story people don't
know that we actually filmed up in this
zero-g airplane that NASA up until that
point and only used for testing of
equipment and and astronaut training and
Ron Howard had the idea to get up there
and film up there and so we did it was
it was quite an experience Larry's gonna
ask you I mean I don't know if that was
a favorite memory I guess depending on
how you look at it but I mean you want
to talk about a story of people in
isolation just a few people coming
together and getting through something
the parallel is kind of funny um do you
have a favorite memory from that set or
anything that you really learned on that
set that you kind of took away with well
it was this real strange thing that
happened where when we were back on the
ground after filming in the neva no
comment
we we were all once we got into our
spacesuits and got into into the you
know the the seats and the in the in the
module we were on a communications live
and it was on the on this line we could
talk to each other and it was me and Tom
and Bill and Ron and there were you know
pretty long times in between setups for
lighting and it was such a hassle to get
in and out of our spacesuits that we
really sat there for four hours
sometimes we always make sure that we
peed like before we got it got into our
spaces we've been knew we were through
you know not good and we had some of the
most hilarious
conversations about all kinds of stuff I
mean I wish that somebody could have
required hope not
in some ways I'm glad that nobody's
recorded but I wish that I could hear it
at least and and it was just just the
four of us just riffing four hours and I
really have very very fond memories of
that you know I'm not yet my hard drive
gets loaded up pretty quickly with stuff
and I tend to dump things off the back
side but I have a feeling that Tom
probably remembers a lot of for what was
said in those in those moments cuz he's
got to cut that kind of brain and it was
it was some funny stuff
[Music]